Jake:那天晚上
Jake: That night.
Alice: 哪天晚上
Alice: Which night?
刘婷:我们认识那天晚上
Liu Ting: The night we met.
Alice: 哇靠
Alice: Wow.
Alice: 恶心
Alice: Gross
Jake: 闭环了呗
Jake: Closed loop, huh?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm
Alice: 受不了了
Alice: Can't take it anymore
Jake: 再来一个
Jake: Another one
Jake: 这么不爱吃饭
Jake: You really don't like eating, huh?
Jake: 你把吃馄饨蘸上呗
Jake: Dip it in wonton sauce
Jake: 哦咱没有是吧
Jake: Oh, we don't have it, do we?
Tasha:不用了
Tasha: No need
Jake: 呃要可以要
Jake: Uh, we can get it if you want
Alice: 我要辣椒面
Alice: I want chili powder
Jake: 对我们好像有存货
Jake: Yeah, I think we have some in stock
Jake: 辣椒油
Jake: Chili oil
Alice:我们还有白芝麻
Alice: We also have white sesame seeds
Tasha:那有
Tasha: Over there
Alice:蘸饺子吃
Alice: Dip the dumplings in it
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm
Jake: 我上去找找
Jake: I'll go look for it
Jake: 我记得有那种小辣包
Jake: I remember we had those small chili packets
刘婷:不用了
Liu Ting: No need
Alice: 问啥呀问
Alice: Why are you asking?
刘婷:别那么没耐心行不行
Liu Ting: Can you be a little more patient?
Alice: 您问
Alice: Go ahead, ask
刘婷:你还记得我们第一次见面
Liu Ting: Do you remember what I was wearing the first time we met?
刘婷:我穿的什么衣服吗
Liu Ting: What clothes was I wearing?
Alice: 哈哈谁他妈记这呀神经病
Alice: Haha, who the heck remembers that? You're crazy
Alice: 我穿什么衣服
Alice: What was I wearing?
刘婷:你穿的就是你这件
Liu Ting: You were wearing this
刘婷:毛衣下面还搭了一条
Liu Ting: This sweater, with a skirt
刘婷:棕色的还是红色的格子裙
Liu Ting: Brown or red plaid skirt
Alice: 你就编吧
Alice: You're just making it up
刘婷:你就说
Liu Ting: Just say it
Alice: 编
Alice: Making it up
刘婷:这个红色
Liu Ting: This red one
刘婷:马甲就是这个
Liu Ting: The vest, this one
Alice: 编
Alice: Making it up
刘婷:什么什么就是编呢本来就是
Liu Ting: What do you mean making it up? It's the truth
Alice:  你放屁
Alice: You're talking nonsense
Alice: 不是这样的
Alice: That's not how it was
刘婷:是这样的
Liu Ting: Yes, it was
Alice:不是这样的
Alice: It's not like that.
Alice:你给我拿证据
Alice: Show me the evidence.
刘婷:你给我拿证据
Liu Ting: Show me the evidence.
Alice:你给我拿证据
Alice: Show me the evidence.
Alice: 你自己非要问这个问题了
Alice: You insisted on asking this question.
刘婷:嗯
Liu Ting: Uh-huh.
刘婷:就是这件
Liu Ting: It's this one.
Alice: 不是这件
Alice: It's not this one.
刘婷:决对是
Liu Ting: It definitely is.
Alice: 不是这件
Alice: It's not this one.
刘婷:哇哇怎么怎么有人这么爱穿红色
Liu Ting: Wow, why does someone love wearing red so much?
刘婷:绝对是
Liu Ting: It definitely is.
Alice: 不是
Alice: No, it's not.
刘婷:那是什么
Liu Ting: Then what is it?
Alice: 那我们那天什么颜色眼影
Alice: What color was our eyeshadow that day?
Alice: 什么颜色眼影
Alice: What color eyeshadow?
Alice: 哼哼
Alice: Hmph.
Alice: 滚
Alice: Get lost.
Alice: 我第一天见你的时候你穿的裤子
Alice: The pants you wore the first day I met you.
Alice: 哈哈哈没有啊
Alice: Haha, no.
Alice: 那我是不是说对了
Alice: Did I get it right?
Alice: 我现在也是
Alice: Me too, right now.
Alice: 赏花去吧
Alice: Let's go admire the flowers.
Alice: 一天啊
Alice: For a day.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Uh-huh.
Alice: 行吗
Alice: Is that okay?
Alice: 他带了GPS
Alice: He brought a GPS.
Jake: 外形高等文明
Jake: Advanced civilization appearance.
Alice: 放胡椒粉了
Alice: Added pepper.
Jake: 我不要啊
Jake: I don't want it.
Jake: 也可以要啊
Jake: Well, I could want it.
Jake: 不要了不要了不要了
Jake: Never mind, never mind, never mind.
Jake: 问候一下问候一下家人们
Jake: Greet the family, greet the family.
Alice: 干嘛 刚刚聊天
Alice: What's up? Just chatting.
刘婷:我一朋友他
Liu Ting: A friend of mine...
刘婷:为情所困
Liu Ting: ...is troubled by love.
Jake: 吾友亦友啊
Jake: My friend is your friend too.
刘婷:啊对我是对
Liu Ting: Ah, right, yes.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Alice: 那个人不是你吧
Alice: That person isn't you, right?
Alice: 不像是你
Alice: 天天没心没肺的
刘婷:神经病吧你
刘婷:用的排除法你知道吗
Alice: 你为啥以前不告诉我你家有这样的别墅
刘婷:你没问啊
刘婷:你也没对我多好啊
Alice: 那我喂你吃饭
刘婷:我吃完了
Alice: 你还吃吗
刘婷:我不吃
Alice: Lucia她们怎么样了
Jake: 我在问
刘婷:她们生病了吗
Alice: 啊
Jake: 啊
Alice: 那不然刚刚
Alice: 刚刚跟你说了
Alice: 有人要去医院让你把道让开
Alice: 我骗你的吗
Jake: 你不是去医院抢救
Jake: Didn't you go to the hospital for an emergency?
刘婷:啊
Liu Ting: Huh?
Jake: 去医院干啥去了
Jake: What were you doing at the hospital?
Jake: 没有没有不是
Jake: No, no, that's not it.
Alice:Lucia旁边的浅头发女孩
Alice: The girl with the light hair next to Lucia.
刘婷:我的天呢
Liu Ting: Oh my god.
Alice: 不然为什么会突然说肠胃炎
Alice: Otherwise, why would she suddenly say she has gastroenteritis?
Alice: 对啊那不就是吗
Alice: Yeah, isn't that the case?
刘婷:哦现实的朋友哦
Liu Ting: Oh, real friends, huh?
Jake: 嗯哼 吾有一友
Jake: Uh-huh, I have a friend...
Alice:绝了
Alice: Incredible.
Jake: 这个确实
Jake: This is indeed true.
Jake: AI可能做的会强一点
Jake: AI might do it a bit better.
Jake: 哈哈在这件事上
Jake: Haha, in this matter at least.
刘婷:打算什么时候走
Liu Ting: When are you planning to leave?
Alice: 再把那个东西再装到
Alice: Let's finish packing that thing up.
Alice: 装完装完收拾下我们就走吧
Alice: Once it's packed, we'll tidy up and go.
刘婷:噢
Liu Ting: Oh.
Alice: 杨老板我们走之前这个你需要拆吗
Alice: Jake, do you need to dismantle this before we leave?
Jake: 嗯我看一下啊
Jake: Hmm, let me take a look.
Alice: 给你拆了我们再走吧
Alice: Let's take it apart before we leave.
Jake: 嗯嗯看下它还能录多久
Jake: Hmm, let's see how long it can still record.
Jake: 我靠
Jake: Oh my gosh.
Jake: 稍等
Jake: Hold on.
Alice: 有何吩咐
Alice: What do you need?
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Jake: 嗯看一下
Jake: Hmm, take a look.
Alice:哎哟
Alice: Ouch.
Alice: 留个纪念吧
Alice: Let's keep a souvenir.
Alice: 哎我手机呢
Alice: Hey, where's my phone?
Alice: 找找
Alice: Look for it.
Alice: 我又不跟他合影
Alice: I'm not taking a picture with him.
Alice: 我就拍他就可以了
Alice: I'm just taking a picture of him.
Alice: 背景是不是有点乱
Alice: Isn't the background a bit messy?
Alice: 确实有点乱这样吧
Alice: It is a bit messy, let's do it like this.
刘婷:但是你谁摄影技术弥补了这一不足
Liu Ting: But your photography skills make up for it.
Alice: 你嘴真甜
Alice: You're so sweet.
Alice: 我真喜欢你
Alice: I really like you.
Alice: 需要拆吗
Alice: Do we need to take it apart?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
刘婷:时刻准备着
Liu Ting: Always ready.
Jake: 拆吧呃
Jake: Take it apart, uh.
Jake: 我要先把它关机
Jake: I need to turn it off first.
Alice: 来吧婷
Alice: Go ahead, Ting.
Alice: 嗯哎呀
Alice: Hmm, oh no.
Alice: 没事先挂着吧
Alice: It's fine, hang it up first.
刘婷:走的时候记得换鞋啊
Liu Ting: Remember to change your shoes before you leave.
Alice: 我现在换
Alice: I'll change now.
Alice: 你不也没换鞋你说我
Alice: You didn't change your shoes either, and you're telling me to.
刘婷:我不着急
Liu Ting: I'm not in a hurry.
Alice: 啊
Alice: Ah.
刘婷:不是很着急
Liu Ting: I'm not in a big hurry.
Alice: 真嘟假嘟嘞
Alice: Are you serious?
Alice: 小姐姐你啊
Alice: Hey, you.
Alice: 下雨了
Alice: It's raining.
刘婷:很大呢
Liu Ting: It's heavy.
Alice: 咱俩打车走
Alice: Let's take a taxi.
Alice:DM啥
Alice: What's DM?
Alice:雨
Alice: Rain.
Alice: 我要唱啥了
Alice: What should I sing?
Alice: 滚不要这个
Alice: Get lost, I don't want this.
Alice:我的暴颜对不起
Alice:真的假的
Alice: Seriously?
Alice:把那个围裙给我拿过来
Alice: Bring me that apron.
Alice: 不是围裙
Alice: Not the apron.
Alice:那个啥
Alice: That thing...
刘婷:窗帘
Liu Ting: The curtain.
Alice:你是不是有毛病啊
Alice: Are you crazy?
Alice:最后一点收拾一下
Alice: Tidy up the last bit.
刘婷:卡布你挺可爱的小狗
Liu Ting: Cappu, you're such a cute little dog.
Alice: 偷
Alice: Steal.
刘婷:啊
Liu Ting: Huh?
Alice:那不然
Alice: Or else what?
刘婷:所所所有的悬疑故事
Liu Ting: All suspense stories...
刘婷:都是发生在雨夜是吗
Liu Ting: ...happen on rainy nights, right?
Alice: 这会露不会
Alice: This won't leak, right?
刘婷:塞子不至于吧
Liu Ting: The plug shouldn't, right?
Alice: 漏了我就骂死你
Alice: If it leaks, I'll scold you to death.
Alice: 刘婷 刘婷 啊啊
Alice: Liu Ting, Liu Ting, ahhh!
刘婷:啊
Liu Ting: Ah.
Alice:你这个特别
Alice: You're so special.
刘婷:你不骂这个香薰品牌的品控
Liu Ting: Aren't you going to scold the brand's quality control?
刘婷:你来骂我
Liu Ting: Why scold me?
Alice: 我只会挑软柿子捏嘛
Alice: I only pick on the easy targets.
刘婷:我服了
Liu Ting: I'm convinced.
Alice: 服了就服了
Alice: If you're convinced, then you're convinced.
Alice: 别叭叭你知道吗
Alice: Stop yapping, you know?
Alice: 你这抽象我真接不住
Alice: I really can't handle your abstractness.
Alice: 有时候你抽象的让我我害怕
Alice: Sometimes your abstractness scares me.
Alice: 住嘴
Alice: Shut up.
Alice: 数据线不收吧
Alice: Are we not packing the data cables?
Alice: 把把那个摄像头给拆了
Alice: Take down the camera.
刘婷:哦对 go
Liu Ting: Oh right, go.
Alice: 老板把它关了吗
Alice: Did the boss turn it off?
Jake: 都关了OK
Jake: Everything's off, okay.
Alice: 拆
Alice: Take it down.
Alice: 你你去拆那个高的
Alice: You, you go take down the high one.
Alice: 那个危险
Alice: It's dangerous.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahahaha.
刘婷:谢谢你哈
Liu Ting: Thank you, ha.
Jake: 对这还是克星
Jake: Yeah, this is still a nemesis.
Jake: 这亲手
Jake: This is handmade.
Alice:还是我亲手粘上的
Alice: I glued it on myself.
Alice: 对亲手钉的线
Alice: Yes, hand-stitched.
Alice: 哎呦卧槽
Alice: Ouch, damn it.
Alice: 那就好好告个别吧
Alice: Well, let's say a proper goodbye.
Alice: 然后什么哪个BGM
Alice: And then, which BGM?
Alice: 就是这个就是这个啊
Alice: This one, this one.
Alice: 你一般那个弄不下来
Alice: You usually can't get that off.
Alice: 你就你先把那个啥给卷下来
Alice: You, first roll that thing down.
Alice: 不不不你把那个摄像头给弄下来
Alice: No, no, no, take the camera down.
Alice: 你可以先拧下来啊
Alice: You can unscrew it first.
Alice: 能听懂我的话吧
Alice: Can you understand me?
Alice: 我对你的智力是没有怀疑的
Alice: I don't doubt your intelligence.
Alice: 婷
Alice: Ting.
Alice: 易如反掌
Alice: Piece of cake.
Jake: 反掌
Jake: Cake.
Alice: 易如反掌
Alice: Piece of cake.
Jake:  掌
Jake: Cake.
Alice:掌
Alice: Cake.
Alice: 哎呦我操
Alice: Ouch, damn.
Alice: 刘婷你一来我说脏话的频率
Alice: Liu Ting, whenever you're around, I swear more.
刘婷:这不应该怪你啊
Liu Ting: You can't blame yourself for that.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
刘婷:不这怎么还有个贴纸呢
Liu Ting: Why is there still a sticker here?
刘婷:我草
Liu Ting: Damn.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Jake: 拆了就放桌上
Jake: Take it apart and put it on the table.
刘婷:哎呦哎
Liu Ting: Ouch, hey.
Jake:这个给我吧
Jake: Give this to me.
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Alice: 哎
Alice: Hey.
Jake:这这个布线
Jake: This wiring.
Jake: 特别的
Jake: Special.
Jake: 我怎么了
Jake: What happened?
Jake: 特别的实在这布线
Jake: This wiring is really solid.
刘婷:明枪易躲暗剑难防唉
Liu Ting: An open attack is easy to dodge, a hidden one is hard to guard against.
Alice: 刘婷我给你变个魔术吧
Alice: Liu Ting, let me show you a magic trick.
刘婷:你不能变
Liu Ting: You can't do that.
Alice: 我非要变呢
Alice: I insist on doing it.
刘婷:那我不看
Liu Ting: Then I won't watch.
Alice: 哈哈我给你变一个
Alice: Haha, I'll show you a trick.
Alice: 我跟你说
Alice: Let me tell you.
Alice: 这桌子底下果然没有人发现
Alice: No one noticed under this table.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Alice:你看这是啥
Alice: Look, what is this?
刘婷:谁躺在桌子底下看啊
Liu Ting: Who would be lying under the table looking?
Jake: 藏的确实挺好
Jake: It's really well hidden.
Alice: 没有人发现
Alice: No one noticed.
刘婷:就是你干的好事
Liu Ting: It's your good deed.
Alice: 我每天都在干好事
Alice: I do good deeds every day.
Alice: 下一个你把这低的留给我
Alice: Next time, leave the low one for me.
Alice: 你去看你去
Alice: You go check it out.
Alice: 摄像头好烫啊
Alice: The camera is so hot.
Jake: 是吧
Jake: Right?
Alice:它已经连续工作好几天了
Alice: It's been working for several days.
Jake: 没有没有没有
Jake: No, no, no.
Jake: 每天都会重启的
Jake: It restarts every day.
Alice: 哦
Alice: Oh.
Alice: 上班了
Alice: Time to work.
Alice: ego nife一勾
Alice: ego knife hook
Alice: 哎哟贴这么黏实干嘛
Alice: Why is this stuck so tight?
刘婷:哎呀
Liu Ting: Oh my.
Jake: 不黏可不行
Jake: It needs to be tight.
Alice: 干嘛刘婷
Alice: What, Liu Ting?
Alice: 怎么了
Alice: What's up?
刘婷:粘的太牢了
Liu Ting: It's stuck too tight.
Alice: 干活比较细致
Alice: I work meticulously.
刘婷:从来 唉哟我的妈呀
Liu Ting: Never, oh my goodness.
刘婷:从来不做豆腐渣工程
Liu Ting: Never do shoddy work.
Alice: 对
Alice: Right.
Alice: 我尚某人出品
Alice: My work can be trusted.
Alice: 你可以相信
Alice: You can trust it.
Alice: 太逆天了
Alice: It's incredible.
Alice: 曾经有人就特别喜欢用逆天这个词
Alice: Someone used to love using the word "incredible."
Alice: 后来呢
Alice: And then?
刘婷:你说呀后来干啥
Liu Ting: Come on, what happened then?
Alice: 后来他倒霉了
Alice: Then he got unlucky.
Alice: 逆天
Alice: Incredible.
Alice: 所以我见你
Alice: So I see you.
Alice: 第一次见你的时候我穿啥衣服
Alice: What was I wearing the first time we met?
刘婷:你穿的就是这个红色啊我印像很深啊
Liu Ting: You were wearing this red one, I remember clearly.
Alice: 不是这衣服
Alice: No, it wasn't this outfit.
Alice: 你死不死 我不知道
Alice: Are you kidding me? I don't know.
刘婷:那是什么呢
Liu Ting: Then what was it?
刘婷:你看吗
Liu Ting: Do you remember?
Alice: 那我反正不是这个
Alice: Well, it wasn't this one.
刘婷:在你手上你不举证我说了也
Liu Ting: If you don't provide evidence, whatever I say...
Alice: 那我看一下我那天有没有拍照准备
Alice: Let me check if I took any pictures that day.
Alice: 再说吧
Alice: We'll see.
Alice: 到时候再看
Alice: We'll look into it later.
Alice: 还有呢
Alice: Anything else?
Alice:对
Alice: Yeah.
Alice:那个危险的就你来吧
Alice: You handle the dangerous part.
Jake: 那个那个我来搞吧
Jake: I'll take care of that.
刘婷:幕布上还有一个哟
Liu Ting: There's another one on the curtain.
Jake: 刘停 哎对摸不上就算 不
Jake: Liu Ting, right, if you can't reach it, just forget it.
Alice:哪有幕布
Alice: Where's the curtain?
Jake: 那那那我来搞吧
Jake: I'll handle that.
Jake: 那你们
Jake: Then you guys...
刘婷:好嘞
Alice:这个这个
Alice: This one, this one.
Jake:太危险了
Jake: It's too dangerous.
刘婷:操作一下操作一下
Liu Ting: Operate it, operate it.
Alice: 易如反掌
Alice: Piece of cake.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Jake: 易如反掌
Jake: Piece of cake.
刘婷:操作一下
Liu Ting: Operate it.
Alice: 人生易如反掌啊
Alice: Life is a piece of cake, huh?
Alice: 你咋不反掌了
Alice: Why aren't you handling it?
Alice: 倒反天罡了是吗
Alice: Are you trying to turn the world upside down?
Alice: 刘婷 刘婷
Alice: Liu Ting, Liu Ting.
Alice: 哎呀卧槽
Alice: Oh my god, what the heck.
Alice: 神经病吧你
Alice: Are you crazy?
Alice: 哎呀
Alice: Oh geez.
Alice: 真弄不下来了
Alice: I really can't get it down.
Alice: 相信自己创造奇迹啊
Alice: Believe in yourself and create miracles.
Katrina:  就是昨天XBZ放桌上的那个头孢
Katrina: So, the cefalexin that XBZ left on the table yesterday...
Katrina:  还在吗
Katrina: Is it still there?
Jake:  呃我找找啊
Jake: Uh, let me check.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 我 靠这东西上哪找去 好
Jake: Where am I supposed to find this thing? Okay.
Jake: 你们记得这个头孢在什么地方吗
Jake: Do you guys remember where the cefalexin is?
Jake: 你们收拾了吗
Jake: Did you guys pack it up?
Alice: 不记得没印
Alice: I don't remember, didn't notice.
刘婷:拿走吃了吧
Liu Ting: Take it and eat it.
刘婷:是不是在二楼冰箱上
Liu Ting: Is it on the fridge on the second floor?
Jake: 找找啊找找看
Jake: Look around, see if you can find it.
刘婷:让那个黄头发的小哥拿走了
Liu Ting: The blonde-haired guy took it.
刘婷:取得下来不
Liu Ting: Should I take it down?
Jake: 等一下我上二楼看看啊
Jake: Wait, I'll go check the second floor.
刘婷:哦 门后还有一个
Liu Ting: Oh, there's another one behind the door.
Alice: 那个你小心点
Alice: Be careful with that one.
Alice: 别把你的脑子砸坏了
Alice: Don't hurt your head.
Alice: 砸坏你的头
Alice: 我会心疼的
Alice: I would feel bad if you did.
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh dear.
Alice: 哎呀
Alice: 空调上是不是还有个呢
Alice: Is there another one on the air conditioner?
Alice: 哦那个拆下来
Alice: Oh, take that one down.
刘婷:拆了那个
Liu Ting: Take it down.
Alice: 哎呦卧槽
Alice: Oh my god.
Alice: 跟本用不上一点劲
Alice: It's completely useless.
Alice: 哎呀
Alice: Oh dear.
Alice: 算了这不行
Alice: Forget it, this won't work.
Jake: 柯欣来找找吧
Jake: Ke Xin, come help find it.
Jake: 要不帮忙
Jake: Or help out.
Alice:啊
Alice: Huh?
Jake: 对找找那头孢
Jake: Yeah, help find the cefalexin.
Alice: 找那个头孢
Alice: Find the cefalexin.
Alice: 是要看他之前吃的什么药是吗
Alice: You want to know what medicine he took before, right?
Jake: 不是不是就是就是
Jake: No, no, just find the cefalexin.
Jake: 找头孢就是找到了
Jake: Yeah, just find it so it can be eaten.
Jake: 就就就能吃是吗
Jake: Yes, it can be eaten.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 行行行
Jake: Okay, okay, okay.
Jake: 好拜拜
Jake: Alright, bye.
Alice: 重新买吗
Alice: Buy it again?
Jake: 可以买
Jake: You can buy it.
Alice: 啊
Alice: Huh?
刘婷:你 能行吗 拔半天了
Alice: 我要梯子干嘛
Alice: Why do I need a ladder?
Alice: 我能够着不是
Alice: I can reach it, can't I?
刘婷:拨不下来的兄弟
Liu Ting: You can't get it off, buddy.
Alice: 哎呀
Alice: Oh, come on.
Alice: 不好意思
Alice: Sorry.
Alice: 让你失望
Alice: I let you down.
Alice: 这还能用第二次吗
Alice: Can this be used again?
Jake: 不那当然
Jake: No, of course not.
Jake: 不管它有没有假
Jake: Doesn't matter if it's fake.
Jake: 只是不在我们的考虑范围内
Jake: It's just not in our considerations.
Alice: 黏糊巴啦的
Alice: It's all sticky.
Alice: 就这吧拆下来拿走
Alice: Let's just take this one down.
Alice: 下一个
Alice: Next one.
Alice:我咋啦
Alice: What happened to me?
Alice: 哦这个很简单
Alice: Oh, this one's easy.
Alice: 完美
Alice: Perfect.
Jake:牛啊
Jake: Awesome.
Alice: 这个太光滑了
Alice: This one is so smooth.
Alice: 丝滑无痛
Alice: Silky and painless.
Alice: 没了吧
Alice: 还有冰箱啊这个
Alice: Oh, there's a fridge too.
Alice: 啊不是冰箱空调
Alice: Oh no, not a fridge, it's an air conditioner.
Alice:刘婷
Alice: Liu Ting
Alice: 你干嘛呢
Alice: What are you doing?
Alice: 就这样
Alice: That's it.
Alice: 你以为呢
Alice: What did you think?
Alice: 没有了好像
Alice: Seems like that's all.
Alice: 这个门上的这个也是我们的吗
Alice: Is this thing on the door ours too?
Jake:  这不是
Jake: Nope, it's not.
Jake: 这是窗帘
Jake: It's a curtain.
Alice:嗯这上面还有一个
Alice: Oh, there's another one up there.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 我靠这这么响
Jake: Whoa, that's loud.
Alice: 卡哇一下子
Alice: Just yank it off.
Jake: 确实就只要劲大他就能弄下来
Jake: Yeah, if you pull hard enough, it'll come off.
Alice: 这是我们的东西吗
Alice: Is this our stuff?
Jake: 我靠这不是
Jake: Whoa, no it's not.
Jake: 哈哈哈我们就贴了一个那个夹子
Jake: Hahaha, we just put a clip there.
Alice: 那我再把它给
Alice: Then I'll just put it back...
Jake: 哈哈哈这东西弄下来得赔钱啊
Jake: Hahaha, taking this down will cost us money.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Alice: 这样不弄
Alice: Don't do it like that.
Alice: 我来吧
Alice: Let me do it.
Alice: 哇哦你好man
Alice: Wow, you're so manly.
Alice: 你好牛
Alice: You're so awesome.
Alice: 帅的嘞
Alice: So cool.
Alice: 这个如果弄不下来的话是不是也要
Alice: If this can't be taken down, does it mean...
Jake: 不知道这问一下别墅
Jake: I don't know, let's ask the villa.
Alice: 用风油精或者啥的
Alice: Use some essential balm or something.
Alice: 然后拿电风扇吹一吹就好弄
Alice: And then blow it with a fan, it'll be easier.
Alice: 风油精那种油的东西
Alice: Essential balm, the oily stuff.
Alice: 好准备走吧
Alice: Alright, ready to go?
Alice:最后一步
Alice: The last step.
Alice:拿上吧
Alice: Take it.
Alice:拿着吧赏你了
Alice: Take it, it's yours.
Alice:明天
Alice: Tomorrow.
Jake: 哎屋子里有伞吗
Jake: Hey, are there any umbrellas in the house?
Jake: 薇薇好像跑出去玩了
Jake: Tasha seems to have gone out to play.
Jake: 回不来
Jake: She can't come back.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Alice: 她她去哪了
Alice: Where did she go?
Jake: 就是雨太大了
Jake: It's raining too hard.
Jake: 你在哪呢
Jake: Where are you?
Jake: where are you
刘婷:啊我有我有
Lucia: Ah, I have one.
Alice: 呜呜呜我去
Alice: Oh my god.
Alice: 不是我以为这有个那个小棚
Alice: I thought there was a small shelter here.
Alice: 这
Alice: This...
Jake: 好搞笑啊
Jake: So funny.
Alice: 这怎么走呢
Alice: How do we go?
Jake: 等等伞呢他
Jake: Wait, where's the umbrella?
Jake: 你把这个伞直接拔下来
Jake: Just take the umbrella directly.
Alice:哈哈哈逆天
Alice: 来去接她哈哈哈
Alice: Let's go pick her up, hahaha.
刘婷:来啦来啦来啦
Lucia: Coming, coming.
Alice: 你的骑士来了
Alice: Your knight is here.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Alice: 当当当当哈哈哈
Alice: Ta-da, hahaha.
Alice: 她俩啊她俩拿伞了
Alice: They got the umbrella.
Jake: 她俩怪惨的
Jake: They both have it pretty rough.
刘婷:拿行礼箱去吧
Liu Ting: Let's take the suitcase.
Alice: 走
Alice: Let's go.
Tasha:哦你们要走了是吧
Tasha: Oh, you guys are leaving, right?
Alice: 对对对
Alice: Yes, yes, yes.
刘婷:对对对
Liu Ting: Yes, yes, yes.
Alice: 打个车
Alice: Let's call a cab.
Alice: 我应该换一个不怕雨的鞋
Alice: I should change to rain-proof shoes.
Alice: 虽然这个也不怎么下
Alice: Although it’s not raining much.
Alice: 嗯那个更不能
Alice: Hmm, that one’s even worse.
Alice: 那个是毛毛的
Alice: That one’s fuzzy.
刘婷:算了
Liu Ting: Forget it.
Alice: 什么算了
Alice: What do you mean forget it?
Alice: 算什么
Alice: Forget what?
Alice: 哎今天你要不跟我一块走
Alice: Hey, if you don’t come with me today,
Alice: 我还走不了了呢
Alice: I wouldn’t be able to leave.
Alice: 是不
Alice: Right?
Alice: 是吧
Jake: 什么时候出去的
Jake: When did you go out?
Alice: 几点了
Alice: What time is it?
Alice: 看一下time
Alice: Check the time.
Alice: please
Alice: Please.
Alice: 我有手机
Alice: I have my phone.
Alice: 我手机呢
Alice: Where’s my phone?
Alice: 那走吧
Alice: Alright, let’s go.
刘婷:别搞
Liu Ting: Don’t mess around.
Alice: 对啊我手机呢
Alice: Yeah, where’s my phone?
Alice: 啊呀
Alice: Ah, geez.
Alice:我们准备走吧
Alice: Let’s get ready to go.
Alice: 哼停止录制
Alice: Hmm, stop recording.
Alice:去西阳
Alice: Heading to Xiyang.